احب اعرفكم على نفسي وعن شخصيتي انا اسمي
سيف عمرو بتخرج من جامعه نيويورك
بحب اسافر بحب اسافر قوي
بحب اسافر عشان بحب اشوف مجتمعات مختلفه
وافهم استاندلز او الطبيعي اللي في كل
كالتشر
سفيره الارجنتين اثيوبيا مكسيك وكذا حته
حوالين العالم
عندي 23 سنه
اه عندي 23 سنه
واقول لكم حاجه بصراحه
انا عمري ما كنت بحب اقول سني
كنت على طول بحس ان الشخص اللي قدامي
هيستظهر اللي احنا بنعمله
عشان فعلا حصل موقف كثيره قدامي زي كده
من انفاسترز لك
[موسيقى]
انا عندي ديسبارير اوير ان لا بلاش تقول
سنك
انا لازم ابين نفسي راجل كبير عندي عشرين
سنه
شركات مالتي ناشونال وبعد كده قررت ابني
شركتي
ناس عندها خمسه سته او حتى عشر سنين
وهو ده اللي انا جاي اكلمكم عنه
لو فاكرين ان الموديلز او الاستاندرز اللي
احنا خلقناها لنفسنا دي حقيقيه
فانا جاي اقول لكم
لان هي اكبر عائق لاننا نحقق حاجه بجد
بس
كوت الواحد بيفكر في شركه
كافس وفي عشرين ثلاثين واحد قاعدين على
مكتبهم وبيجراينت
نو
ممكن تبقى شويه اللي هقوله ده بس في
الحقيقه احنا ابتدينا من الجامعه عندنا في
انويو اكتشفنا مشكله
او جاب في الماركت قدامنا محتاج فلوس
قعدنا اسبوع بنفكر واسبوع كمان بنعمل مع
الطلاب بنفهم مشاكلهم في الجامعه وايه
الحلول اللي بيلجاوا لها عشان هو ده اول
الطريق تفهم العميل اللي انت بتخاطبه ايه
هي مشاكله وهل حلك يقدر يساعده فعلا ولا
لا
هنا مش انك تجهز درايه انفيرمنت
انك تبدا عشان ده عمره ما يحصل
المورل انك تبدا ابدا
والجميل اللي في الموضوع ان التيل ده لما
كنا في الجامعه ان وجودنا كطلاب في وسطهم
هو اللي ساعدنا
وهو ده اول طريق الصح وسبحان الله ممكن لو
انا كان عندي عشرين سنه اكسبرينز ما كانش
هيبقى عندي ولا اللانجويتش اللي هتعرف
تقربني للكا من ده اللي هو طلاب الجامعه
ده تيك اوتر
اللي هو سني كيم تو بي ان اسيد مش اديس
ده علمنا حاجه تانيه حاجه اصبحت او نورس
في اللي احنا بنعمله
[موسيقى]
ماركه الجامعات
و
عملت انترفيوس
والفكره ايه استبس اللي بعديها
اعمل منتج واثبت ان الناس هتدفع فلوس في
البرادت او السيرفس اللي انت بتعمله طبعا
بتاع الناس لما بتفكر او بتسمع حاجه زي
كده منتج وفلوس
ودبس تماما
جرب المنتج بابسط بارخص واسرع طريقه عشان
تخلي الناس تتكا كميه من طيور
السيرفس اللي انت بتقدمها ان اول كيس احنا
عملنا الام في بي على ويب سايت بلدر
وعملنا شويه ايه احسن جامعه هنبتدي فيها
واستقرين على اي سي هنا
ونزلناه السوق من غير اي ماركتنج وكان
بوست كده على الجامعه الحمد لله لقينا
الوريده
يوم ورا يوم طيب حلو قوي
الموضوع دخل في الجد
قلنا جميل سالنا نفسنا سؤال
هنبتدي الاسكيل ندخل الجامعه دي والجامعه
دي والجامعه دي
قلنا لا
لا
يلا نتعلم يعني ايه
ندخل
نتعلم اكتر يعني ايه وازاي الواحد يبني من
فكره لشركه ومن شركه لمنتج الناس بتستخدمه
كل يوم
قعدنا نتعلم ونروح من انكبيتر في نيويورك
لابوظبي لكايرو وابتدينا ندخل وبفضل ربنا
بنكسبها
بس هدفنا ما كانش اي حاجه غير اننا نتعلم
عشان تبقى نور لازم تبقى عندك لازم تبقى
بتسترايف ان كل يوم تتعلم
معناها انك بتاخد الحاجه
ومع كل ستات بتقيس انت كشركه اتعلمت ايه
وعلى اساس اللي انت اتعلمته
وهتقعد تقتل التاني وتاني وتحسن تاني
وتاني لغايه ما توصل للفورم للصح
اللي اتاكد لك انت اكيد انت فعلا اللي
قدامك
طيب
جميل عايزين راس مال بقى
قعدنا مع الامارات في سي ده اللي هو اللي
مش عارفين في سي ده اللي هو شركه
استثماريه
قعدنا معاهم
اول قاعده كده
وعايز اقول لكم كانوا منبهرين وعاجبهم قوي
الفكره بتاعتنا حتى واحد فيهم قعد يحكي لي
عن مدى هو كان يستخدم الويب سايت بتاعنا
وهو في الجامعه
بعديها بيومين لقيته قاعد في ايميل انهم
يليد
ما كنتش مصدق بقى ومبسوط قوي
وابتدى بقى يتعرف علينا اكتر
اول ما سمع ان انا لسه طلاب
والشول
طلاب
طب ومين شغال معكم
لا حضرتك احنا الاربعه لسه طلاب
خلصنا الميتينج وبعديها بيومين
لقيتهم بيبعتوا لي ايميل تاني
بصراحه
كنت محبط
لاني قعدت افكر طب هو انا بعمله ده صح ولا
غلط
هل اصبر على
واشتغل شويه وبعدين ارجع لها ولا ولا اعمل
ايه
بس ليه ما احنا شغالين كويس وعاملين من
جوه اذا كنت شهر بعد شهر كان قدامي حاجه
من حاجتين يا اما استيك
اغلبيه الناس حوالي كانوا بيعملوا بيقدموا
على شغل هنا وهنا وهنا يا اما اعمل
والحمد لله ربنا حطني على الطريق الصح
بس بينقل
ده مش معناها انك مش ممكن او تغير حاجات
بالعكس
بس اللي انا عايز اقوله
انك خلي عندك
كمان شهر
الشركه بتكبر وعدد الموظفين
ابتدوا يطلع اكتر ومشاكل اكبر
قلت طيب
الناس دي ازاي
انا ولا اكس جوجل ولا اكس فيسبوك انا سيف
عمرو عادي
ابتديت ادرس الموضوع
مع وجود ناس اكبر مني في السن
وكان تركيزي على ان ازاي ابني تيم كالتشر
ماشي على
فاليوز معينه انا ماسسها ويبقى هو ده
لايت بشوفها قدامي
طبعا ده جزء كبير منه
بس لا اصبح المشن دي هي الفيول اللي بتخلي
التيم شغال وعايز يكبر شركتنا
عشان هي ما بقتش
شركتي او شركه يوسف او مريم او سامر لا
بقت شركتنا بقت حاجه كلنا مهتمين اننا
نشوفها بتكبر يوم بعد التاني
وماي فاشن بقى هو الحاجه اللي انا بليب
بها
بقوا بيشوفوني قاعد لغايه الساعه تسعه في
الاوفيس عشان اخلص شغل بقى كل حد في التيم
مستعد يقعد لغايه تسعه مجرد انه عايز يقاد
فاليو
عايز يبقى جزء من ده
بس عارفين
حاجه اكتشفتها متاخر شويه
مشكله الباشن انه ما بينو وما بين اوبسيشن
خط رفيع قوي
اغلبيه الوقت الواحد مش بيشوفه
يبقى
مش مفيد ولا للشركه
وبالذات لما بتكون لسه شاب صغير او ما
عندكش قوي بتبقى مستعد تحرق كل اللي عندك
عشان تشوف اللي انت عايزه بيتحقق
بس اقدر اقول لكم
ان ده مش صح يونيت
ومش هضحك عليك انا لسه بدور عليه بره
بس زي ما قلت لكم
اخر حاجه حابب اقولها لكم هي كود من وانا
في مايرول مودنس واحد كده اسمه ستيف جوبز
ممكن تكونوا سمعتوا عنه عمل شركه كده
اسمها قبل
كان بيقول
ده
سكوير هولز
[تصفيق]
طيب